- I got this present, and it reads, "To Evan
Carmichael, merry Christmas and happy New
Year, "with lots of love from Believe Nation."
- [Female] Do you want to watch it?
- These are my top 10 videos.
- You going to watch it?
- I'm a little scared.
- He's a former venture capitalist, radio
host, YouTube personality and entrepreneur.
- He sold his first company at 19.
- He set two world records.
- He aimed to help while being an entrepreneur.
- He's Evan Carmichael and here are his top
10 rules for success.
- When I was growing up in grade two, grade
three, grade four, I used to have a lot of
nervous ticks.
Some of them were really embarrassing.
I used to blink a lot constantly.
I used to do this with my neck and then have
to adjust with my shoulder.
When I was walking I used to always have to
step on the lines or completely avoid the
lines in the sidewalk.
One of the most embarrassing one was I used
to always try to kick my own butt where I
would always have the, I'd have to push my
leg up and I wouldn't be happy until the heel
hit my butt.
And I have to do that a couple times before
I can move on with the rest of my day.
I was also getting into a lot of fights at
my school.
So seeing this, my parents were really worried.
And they took me to go see a child psychologist.
I didn't know she was a psychologist.
My parents just said I was going to go play
games with somebody and we had some games
together and she showed me these ink blots
and told me, "What do you see in these pictures?"
And she asked me a bunch of questions.
The immediate recommendation was that I switch
schools right away.
And so in grade five I transferred to a new
school called Crescent and ended up staying
there from grade five all the way to graduating
high school.
And the ticks got better.
For the most part they went away completely.
To this day I still have a few minor ones
where if I'm thinking or if I'm stressed or
if I'm tired, you can see my ears move.
But other than that, they're gone.
What it really made me think about was the
importance of your environment.
See, your environment is either something
that builds you up, that lifts your spirits,
that helps you go chase your dreams.
Or it's something that squashes you down.
That makes you shrink.
That makes you accept a lesser life.
So think about the people that you surround
yourself with, think about the TV shows you're
watching and the media that you're consuming
and the place that you go to work.
Does your environment build you up or squash
you down?
Changing my environment had a dramatic impact
on the quality of my life and the contribution
to my success as an entrepreneur.
Achieving yours can have the same impact for
you.
- Add more value.
If you want to be able to charge what you're
worth, if you want to be able to build a successful
company, you need to add a ton of value.
The amount of money that you make will be
directly related to how much value you're
providing for your customers.
How much you're helping them out.
It's a pretty simple equation.
Executing it is difficult.
But the concept is simple to understand.
If you want to make more money add more value
and stop competing on price.
When you compete on price alone it's a loser's
game.
You're not going to bring on ideal clients.
You're constantly going to be struggling to
get by.
You're not going to be able to hire great
people for your team.
You have to stop competing on price, start
adding more value and you're going to love
your business more.
You're going to have more fun.
You're going to attract much better clients.
You want to work with people who understand
the value you provide and not just cater to
the guys who have no budget who are barely
paying you a tiny profit for what you're doing.
I believe everybody has one word that they
stand for and when you figure out what that
one word is, your life and your business will
change.
And it's not just for marketing, it's not
just how you promote yourself, but it's who
your surround yourself with, the team that
you attract yourself to, the products and
service that you launch.
When I encompanied and embraced believe as
my one word, my business started to take off.
My videos started doing insanely better.
I started attracting the right people into
my team.
I started launching products that made sense
for people and people really embraced.
And so I'm a huge believer in it and I'm going
to give you a quick method to how to figure
out your one word.
The first step is you think about what makes
you happy.
What are the things that make you come alive?
What are the things that you love doing?
And just, don't even think about what your
one word is yet.
Just think about all the things that you love
doing, things you could do all day long, and
things that fill your life with joy.
Write those things down.
And this isn't just a business thing, this
is you personally.
'Cause you want to make this personal for
your business to be successful.
The second this is that look at what connects
them.
What are all the things that connect those
things that make you happy?
What's the connective tissue and try to figure
out is there one word that can bring all those
things together?
So think about what your favorite movie is,
your favorite book, your favorite, your best
friend growing up, what you love about your
parents, you know, what businesses you've
been attracted to, the hobbies that you love
doing.
What connects them all together?
For me it's believe.
You know, I love Seabiscuit as a movie which
is about this underdog horse.
And underdog jockey and underdog trainer and
underdog owner and how they all work together
to then win a whole bunch of races.
The songs that I listen to are always the
uplifting, believe, kind of positive ones.
Those are the ones that I gravitate towards.
What I love about my parents is that they
always believed in me and told me that I was
a Carmichael and I could do anything that
I wanted.
Even if they didn't give me the ideas on how
to start a business, they always believed
that whatever I did I would be successful
at and taught me to believe in myself.
And so it's real important.
And so all of those things that I've done
across my life have been about believe and
when I encompass that it allowed me to start
living my life on purpose, with direction,
instead of just being reacting to it.
The thing is that every industry is competitive.
Right, every industry is competitive.
And the key is you got to be you.
The key thing that's going to make you stand
out from everybody else is you.
I'm trying to cross the street as I'm saying
this.
That's the differentiator.
That's your market advantage.
And so you got to figure out, yes, you can
model success.
Yes, you can look at people who are big in
the beauty industry and look at how they rose
and those are great examples.
You've got to take what worked for them and
then make it your own.
You've got to find a way to make this your
business and people will be attracted to your
personality.
Not everybody, but a certain group of people.
And what I found the best way to do it is
to combine your passions.
So if you love beauty, that's amazing, that's
awesome, what else do you love?
And how can you mix those two things?
So for example, say you love dancing.
Right, you love dancing, that's your passion
besides beauty.
Be the beauty person for dancers.
Right?
The next time doing a photo shoot, the next
time they're getting ready for a performance,
the next time they're out there getting to
a movie, I almost got run over by that guy.
Holy cow.
They're going to call you, right?
You're making videos, you're writing the blog
post, you're Tweeting about makeup and beauty
and dancing.
And so that's the key, that's how you do it.
A couple examples that I've used before in
the video, one, if you like being a photographer,
photographers are super competitive, too.
But say you love bowling.
Then you can be the photographer for bowlers.
And you're going to be the default person
they go to because they need people to be
able to take pictures and they want somebody
who's passionate about bowling.
If you love dancing, they need people who
can do makeup but they want people who are
passionate about dancing as well and you can
speak both languages.
That's the key.
I got a buddy of mine, I've used an example
before, named Steve, who's a financial planner.
A financial planner?
How many financial planners are there out
there?
Tons.
But he has a passion for hockey.
He loves hockey, he obsesses over it, he watches
it, you know, as much as he can.
Watches the same replay 20 times.
He can just watch hockey day in and day out.
He became the financial planner for hockey
players.
And so when he's talking to hockey players,
now, he can speak their language, he can talk
about hockey, he can talk about investments
and he's one of them.
Right?
A lot of these hockey players, you know, the
goal in financial planning is to target the
high net worth individuals, right?
The people who have a lot of money.
Those are the people you want to work with.
And so he's able to do that by combining his
passions.
And so make it your own, right?
Find a way to be able to tie whatever other
passions you have into the beauty business
and that's how you're going to stand out.
I want to see more of this, I want to see
your passion, I want to see your personality,
your character, what you believe in.
All of that, it's got to be real, it's got
to be you, it's got to be human and that connection
to you and everything that you stand for and
believe in is what's going to make me want
to come to you as opposed to everybody else.
That's how you stand out.
One of the most important lessons that I've
learned in business, and I guess in life,
is you need to follow your flow.
And sometimes there are external pressures
that force you into following your flow.
You may get a big meaty opportunity.
You may get a partnership.
You may get a big customer that kind of is
a huge, big opportunity for your business.
And sometimes follow your flow, I find, comes
from internal reasons.
Internal pressures.
Maybe you wake up one day and you really want
to go try something out.
Or you're on a walk or you're in the shower
and a new thing comes to your mind.
And I found that by following my flow, by
following that idea, it's always in my best
interest.
One, because probably magic is going to happen.
If magic is going to happen it's going to
come from a source of inspiration.
Not just being, you know, doing your day to
day to day to day.
And two, I didn't want to live with regret,
you know?
Didn't want to have this big list of to-do's.
This big list of ideas that just builds and
builds and builds and this Evernote file that
just keeps growing and I never actually take
action on stuff, right.
You have an idea, you want to try something,
go and take action on it.
So yesterday, because this relates to my book,
yesterday I had a full day planned.
Monday is my busy day.
I record these on Tuesdays.
Mondays are my busiest day of the week.
And I had a full day planned and it all exploded
on me.
From an external source.
From 50 Cent.
So I made a video and 50 Cent saw it and he
called it, "Good shit."
And he posted on his Facebook page and he
posted it to his Twitter account.
He posted a blog about it.
He kind of went crazy promoting this and as
a result the traffic exploded on my video,
comments were coming out of everywhere.
People were Tweeting me, they're signed up
for my newsletter.
They're engaging with the video.
It was just insane.
And I had a choice of hey, I could either
go with this, right, or I could just do all
the work that I had planned for the day.
And I chose to go with it.
On top of it, it was pretty cool, right?
50 Cent likes my stuff and is sharing it and
I spent a good amount of time just with my
team just having fun in the moment.
Looking at the numbers, seeing where it was
being shared, it's kind of a big celebration
and a win for everybody on the team.
So we're all kind of super pumped and excited.
And I spent the day responding to everybody
and as a result, got nothing done that I was
supposed to get done for the day.
Hello Believe Nation.
I talked a lot about, on this channel, how
when you first start at something you're going
to suck at it, right?
Any new skill that you kind of pick up, you're
going to suck whether it's learning a language,
picking up a new sport, picking up a new skill,
learning the video games, trying to understand
marketing or accounting, whatever it is you're
trying to understand, you will suck at the
start.
And the story I've told a couple of times
on these videos is look back on my channel,
look back on old videos and see the progress,
right?
2500 videos later you can see how I've grown
and I've gotten better and I sucked at the
start.
And hopefully sucked a little bit less now.
But one thing that struck me as I was watching
through my channel was the Entspresso series.
I started that a couple months ago and the
first one that I did was of Dame Dash.
And it was a selfish project for me because
I wanted something in the morning to kind
of get me excited, get me inspired, make me
think bigger.
But when I started it I didn't have it all
planned out and I think this is something
that's really critical for a lot of you entrepreneurs
is you want to not over plan and expect to
suck at the start.
And it's okay because you're going to get
better and better and better and better.
- I remember when I had my first company,
I really struggled at the beginning.
I was making 300 bucks a month, not enough
to survive.
Almost gave up repeatedly and was willing
to try anything.
I felt like I had tried everything and nothing
was working out.
I had a great product and I couldn't understand
why this was so hard because the books I've
read and the websites I've visited, and the
shows I watched, everything seemed to be so
easy.
Like, follow these eight steps and you'll
be successful.
Well I've followed those eight steps a million
times and I wasn't successful.
And one of the big breakthroughs for me came
when I realized that I wasn't the first guy
to try to do this before.
My first company was a software company and
I had no background in software before.
Apart from using a computer, but I wasn't
a software designer.
And the breakthrough moment came when I did
realize that I'm not the first guy to try
to sell software before and I went and I modeled
some of the largest and most successful software
companies in the world.
And one in particular was Microsoft.
And again, I don't care how Bill Gates makes
money now but how did you go from nothing,
from that idea, to getting his first customer.
What did he do, what did he say, what were
his options, what was his mindset?
Who did he need to connect with?
And I took those strategies and applied them
to my business and I finally started to see
results.
For him it was through partnerships.
So he made partnerships, he had software,
he partnered with hardware companies.
His big deal came with IBM, it was a seven
million dollar deal, that first one with IBM
that really put the company on the map but
before that he still made partnerships with
other hardware companies.
And they sold their products as a bundle.
And so I applied that strategy and within
the first month I closed my first partnership
deal and I made 13 and a half thousand dollars.
Now that may not seem like a lot of money
to you, 13K, but to me I'm making 300 bucks
a month, this was like eureka.
Oh my God, I struck it rich.
This is amazing.
Somebody actually believes in what I'm doing.
I'm seeing some positive momentum finally
after all this failure and struggling.
And I just kept copying that again, and I
applied it again and again and again and closed
more partnerships and more partnerships and
continued to grow my business and eventually
I got acquired by someone who was a potential
partner.
They loved us so much that they wanted to
buy my business.
And I wish I had discovered it earlier.
I wish I'd discovered the strategy so much
earlier.
Because I almost shut down.
Like, I almost quit my business and thought
maybe I should listen to my friends and go
back and get a job.
And I'm so grateful that I didn't but I came
close many times to having to do that.
And so if you're struggling with your business
right now, if you don't have a lot of experience
in the field and it's a first time thing for
you, you can't get this thing off the ground,
model success.
Find someone who has done it, who's had success
in your field.
Look at the cosmetic alliance company, see
how they did it, learn from their mistakes
so you don't have to make all the mistakes
yourself.
And you crunch down your learning curve so
instead of it taking you years and years and
years to achieve success you can do it a lot
faster because you're modeling things that
work.
That's the test.
You know, when you are excited by something,
when you are passionate about something, when
you're willing to set an alarm for something
and then wake up even before that alarm goes
off, that tells you that you're on the right
path because too many people try to plan it
all out, right.
Try to make it make sense up here in your
head, right?
It's got to make total logical sense before
I launch.
And your assumptions are always going to be
wrong.
And it's never going to work out like you
think it will and you spend so much time planning
that you don't spend any time doing.
And what you need to do is follow your passion
even when it sounds crazy.
You know, I don't know how this business is
going to work out.
I don't know if it's going to be with videos,
I don't know if it's going to be through an
agency, through tournaments, through representing
players, I don't know what it's going to be.
But what I do know is if I don't do anything
nothing's going to happen.
And so by following my passion and by waking
up early and setting that alarm clock and
getting excited about something, we'll explore,
we'll try, we'll fail, we'll make mistakes
and we'll get better and we'll find our path.
And you need to do the same thing, too.
If there's something that you are excited
about, something that you want to try, then
start.
Start, even if it doesn't make any sense.
Because by trying and making mistakes and
figuring it out, you'll land on the perfect
business model to help you explode and grow
when everybody else thought you were crazy.
One of the things that I fundamentally believe
is that entrepreneurs make the world a better
place.
This is, we are the people that drive forward
progress.
We're the people that create the change and
one of the main reasons why I make these videos
and I'm so passionate about helping out entrepreneurs
is because you guys are the ones that's going
to go out and create that better future for
my kids and for my grandkids.
And so just as a reminder, if you're struggling
to, I know there's like the short term cash
flow crunch and you want to make money now,
you're trying to figure out how to survive.
And survival is important but the way to get
to becoming a successful entrepreneur is by
impacting people and some people have a big
vision like Walt Disney and want to create
new cities and other entrepreneurs have a
smaller vision.
And all you want to do is help your local
community and help your customers who are
buying from you.
But at the core of every successful business
is a desire to do good and to make the world
a better place.
That's what drives me.
I want to have a big impact and I know I can
help people on a small scale.
I know I can help you with the videos and
the videos are taking off and everything I've
done is, you know, is growing quickly.
But I want it to be bigger, right?
I want it to be life changing on a world scale.
And I don't always believe that I can do it.
Because I've never done it before.
Because it seems like such a big goal.
And I'm writing a book right now.
And it's, I want it to be an important book.
I want it to be one of the top 10 most read,
most valuable business books of all time.
And that's an easy goal to say, right?
Anybody can say I want to have this book to
be the top 10 book, anybody can say that.
But who actually believes that?
Right?
Do I actually believe that I can write that
book?
Because if I don't, I'm not going to write
that book.
And when I'm talking to people I'm not going
to get them excited and there's a fine line
between confidence and arrogance or cockiness
but that's the challenge that I'm going through
right now is believing that I can create this
amazing book.
And when I'm talking to Jessica Alba I'm saying
hey, you're a superhero in the movies but
you should be a superhero in real life as
well.
You can be a superhero for entrepreneurs.
And help them and be a model for success for
your Honest Company.
I have to do that with a lot of confidence.
I have to do that believing that this is truth.
- Thank you so much for watching.
- Yo, we made this video--
- Because we love you so much Evan Carmichael.
- And his fans asked us to.
- We'd also like to know which of Evan's top
10 rules meant the most to you.
- Leave it in the comments.
- We will join you in the discussion.
- Thank you so much for watching.
- Continue to believe.
- And we'll see you soon.
- Bonus, uh-oh.
What's in the bonus, what's in the bonus.
- Are you serious?
Jesus Christ.
Can you stand up a little bit more?
- Aw man, it's yummy.
Mmm, the red wine sauce?
The red wine makes it.
- Okay, thank you for watching this video.
If you liked the video please give us thumbs
up.
And enjoy, subscribe.
Bye.
Believe.
Why you looking at me?
- It's great.
- Oh.
- Stop it.
Baby, can you help me?
Oh, you're too far, you're too tall.
Just stand back.
- Mm, it's good, made fresh.
Two thumbs up, high five.
Muah.
- Ready?
Oh, it's really good.
Really?
Oh my God.
Okay.
You're going to break this thing.
Just jump.
Are you okay?
- Before we go in I got to give props to Tim
Horton's.
They changed their straw on their ice caps,
it's this red thing now, but it's way stronger.
So when you mix the drink it's a lot easier
and the straw doesn't bend so Nina will demonstrate
because I have a hand, look.
- You have a hand?
I know you have a hand.
- See, the straw doesn't bend.
Props to you Tim Horton's.
Amazing work.
These are the kinds of things you learn on
the Evan Carmichael channel.
Sandra listen to me, you need to get out of
there.
Was that good?
Sandra listen to me.
You need to get out of there.
Was that close?
So if you want to tell me how Americans say
out differently than Canadians, and maybe
give your own example.
- Please subscribe to the channel and believe.
Bye, okay say bye.
Okay.
- Bye.
- So.
Oh I forgot what I want to say, I forgot now.
Okay, stop you're interrupting.
You're interfering with my thought.
- Okay, here we go.
One, two.
Nothing.
Squeeze the bottle.
Just like that.
And you're done.
Thank you.
Amazing.
Continue to believe.
I really appreciate.
I was waiting for someone to step up and do
it.
I was waiting.
I challenged people in the comments a couple
times so it's great, it's an awesome Christmas
present.
Feeling the love, I know a lot of work went
into that.
So thank you guys.
And we'll have an amazing 2016 together.